okay
so visually this is the most
different looking star wars movie out of
the whole bunch that i've seen
but the whole thing's on a green screen
so you know i guess you take some you
lose some
um anyway so
a lot of people told me that i would
enjoy the prequels more than the
original trilogy which wasn't true for
fandom
phantom menace and it's not true for
this one but they told me that i would
because of the politics
here's the thing about politics and
science fiction yeah i like politics
that you know make sense
and it's not totally you know dumb
or whatever um that's the thing about
these prequels there's there's things in
them
that's kind of cool it's kind of good
and then there's stuff in them that's
just
so bad okay
this movie is one of the worst
worst romances that i've ever seen
that i've ever seen anywhere so
i was so happy that the kid from phantom
menace
wasn't in this but he gets re replaced
by hayden christensen
it's like a teenage heartthrob or
whatever and he's not even
he's not any better than the [ __ ] kid
holy sh
okay i know that natalie portman is a
good actress
so considering the fact that i know
natalie portman is a good actress and i
know that evan mcgregor is a good actor
i have to imagine that it's like the
directing and the writing
that that's ruining all of this because
there are just some
freaking just terrible cringey lines
any time they try to do this romance
thing between anakin and padme i'm just
like
not buying it i'm not buying it and then
at the end
at the end they're just married they
just get married at the end i'm like oh
my god
when did we have the time to establish
this it was just
it was very shoehorned it was not
believable it was very much
we've got plot points to get to let's
just
okay now let's do this now let's do this
it doesn't matter how they connect
together
and then like i said just like the first
one the movie's like half cartoon
okay the most ridiculous sequence in the
movie i felt like
was like you have everyone that matters
off somewhere
doing something with guns and going pew
pew and i gotta say you know at least
natalie portman's character is still
like doing stuff in this movie she's
like you know she's
killing people with guns she's doing the
pew thing whatever at least she's still
doing stuff she's not just like sitting
on the sidelines so that's cool she's
not like totally like just like i'm a
damn so i'm not like she's not just like
anakin's girlfriend
so that's awesome so she's still doing
things you got anakin
who's like learning about you know the
force and he's kind of like
a little bit uh subversive he's just he
kind of has
disagreements with the jedi yada yada
and you also have this other guy darth
sidious
who's obviously evil
you know this is the thing this is the
thing when you get when you got the dark
lord
and i'm and i'm supposed to think oh
people actually believed he was a good
guy i mean he's obviously
evil i mean like holy [ __ ] this guy's
like
how can you how can you i don't
understand how
anyone can be around this guy and not
realize that he's just like totally
freaking evil
anyway like what is this movie about
anyway so they have this
there is this cgi
battle between droids
and the jar jar binks people and that's
happening at the same time while
everyone else that matters
is like off like you know fighting and
so in some building somewhere
so it was just really
why why well so it's like it's like
it's like we're cutting to you know
actual people and then we cut back to a
cartoon
cut to actual people cut back to a
cartoon whose idea was this
to have this very disjointed battle
scene when we have like
part cartoon and part you know live
action and i call it a cartoon
because it looks like a cartoon you know
very good cgi looks really good
you know lord of the rings i keep
thinking lord of the rings had great cgi
and came out around the same time as
this looked really good the cgi and this
is just freaking bad for no reason and i
don't get it jar jar binks as a
character is still
really really really annoying see look
my dilemma here is i really wanted to
give this movie a chance i wanted to
give these prequels a chance
but i don't know how i'm expected to
take this seriously because it's not
serious at all
this is not a serious effort
i don't know what went wrong with these
prequels but this is just like a whole
another level it's like these the other
movies were competent
i don't see competence here all right
for me highlight of this movie though
was was
count dooku and yoda why was that so
cool
that was really cool right i liked it i
liked it and even i thought the cg
on yoda was actually pretty decent cgi
yoda
is not it's not so bad cgi yoda
that wasn't that wasn't too bad so yeah
and also i will say
because i didn't mention this in my
other review the lightsaber battles
in these movies i like them
i feel like i've seen somewhere vaguely
on the internet
i think people criticize the lightsaber
battles in these movies
but i personally think if you've got two
force sensitive people fighting each
other with lightsabers
it's gonna look less like a battle as in
a struggle and it's gonna look more like
a dance because they're gonna be
anticipating each other's moves and all
that stuff
so you know i liked i like the elegant
appearance of the battles in in these
movies
i thought it looked pretty good yoda
doing force lightning
was kind of confusing to me even though
it was still cool i thought that was
maybe like just like a sith thing
but apparently the jedi can do it too or
really powerful jedi
so that scene that's i think that's a
trick that they should pull out more
often because the lightning is pretty
useful
so yeah so count dooku escapes
but and i guess he'll show up in the
next movie and so it'll finish out the
trilogy
so um this movie wasn't very good
i think it was a little bit better than
the first one i think it was a little
bit better than the first one
but overall both of these movies
for me have get a failing grade
get a failing grade i feel like they
could have been done much
much better you there could have been a
lot more thought put into these
um these are these are the star wars
prequels you know one of the greatest
trilogies of all time
and this is and this is this is what
we're doing we're making it
half cartoon we're making it this goofy
we're really
diving this far into the goofiness
territory
because it's like you're trying to give
me like it's like it's like two movies
pushed together because you're trying to
give me like this like kind of
pseudo-serious politics thing
but it's in this totally unrealistic
setting with these totally
this totally clearly evil guy that no
one should trust
and it's just like i don't understand
how this is
supposed to be believable and then it's
got like weird cgi characters everywhere
and it's just
it's not good it's very very messy and
yeah i just didn't
like it very much but we'll see what the
final one
is like i hear people say that the third
one is the best out of these three
i guess we'll see uh
or whatever and then i'll be off to
watch attack of the clones the tv show
and i guess i'll do mandalorian and all
the other movies and it'll be fun we'll
go on a whole star wars adventure
together
i'm sorry you've had to listen to me
trash two movies in a row
i have to be honest but that's it
peace out guys make sure you like and
subscribe for more quinn's ideas
and definitely follow me on twitter for
all of the antics that are
happening there peace out